well hello they're watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the deputy
comment editor at the telegraph
Annabelle Denham and the political
editor of the Guardian peppercareer with
us from now until just before midnight
welcome to both of you so let's check
out some of those front pages so we're
starting with the sun which leads with
the allegation made against a BBC
presenter their headline from the father
of the young person diming the BBC Liars
the guardian also focusing on the BBC
story quoting the statement from the
lawyer of the young person calling the
claims rubbish
and the eye does the same BBC presenter
did nothing wrong claims the young
person at the center of the sex photo
scandal
well let's go straight to our guests on
this then lots more papers coming in for
us as well um Pippa the story still
dominating a number of newspapers
certainly
um bring us what your thoughts are first
of all on the sun which is doubling down
effectively on their story
yes that's right I mean this is a story
which is dominated headlines
um not just today but uh over the last
few days since the sun broke this story
these allegations about a BBC presenter
at the weekend
um and effectively what the sun's doing
is doubling down it's a very bold front
page they say that the BBC are liars
they are accusing the BBC of ignoring
warnings from uh The Young Person's
family back in May seven weeks ago they
claimed that they approached the BBC
um and had a conversation with them and
that no action was taken and that this
presenter remained on air
um they said that they had screenshots
of contact between the presenter and
their and their child who is now 20.
um and
um the uh they have obviously reacted to
um to events um ongoing events the
police Metropolitan Police said today of
course it is still considering whether
to Launch an investigation into these
allegations
and it's really up the ante uh there's a
bit like I say it's a very it's a very
bold front page and
um I imagine that there's probably some
nerves in the sun Newsroom tonight uh
having made the decision
um to to double down on the original
story
um and they've spoken again I think it's
the stepfather of the young person who's
saying that they uh stick by their
original original tale and that they are
acting only to protect their child who
uh allegedly
um was using he was using this money to
to fund the drug habit so you know it is
it looks like a bit of a mess really
um and different sides in this story are
saying
um different things obviously it's
legally very very tricky
um but inevitably Intrigue follows and
you know the drama of today means that
more and more people will be will be
paying attention to this story so I
think we can only hope this is resolved
one way or another very soon yes Nana
believe the weekend you know we were
reminded that this is complex certainly
that is proving um to be the case
um you know weirdly we have he says she
says um you know within a family it
appears who knows
um and you know effectively the BBC and
the the sun put it slightly pitted
against each other here now
yes that's absolutely right quite
extraordinary to have the Sun newspaper
going up against the public service
broadcaster um it's been an absolutely
extraordinary day we began really by
with further speculation particularly on
social media about who the individual in
question might be who the BBC high
profile prominent presenter might be and
we thought that we were rounding off the
day with this bombshell letter from uh
the lawyer representing the young person
at the center of this story the lawyer
claiming that um there's the mistakes
have been made that this is um and I
quote totally wrong
um and we thought perhaps that might be
the end of at least for this Monday but
um no the some have come out very
robustly in response
um to these uh these accusations as
Pippa says
um you know that the family have said
that they were coming out to help the
vulnerable child uh saying that they had
made this complaint to BBC didn't feel
as though it was being given due
attention they put these allegations to
them for an hour you know it's just
quite an extraordinary story and I think
as Perth says you know unfortunately
there is that Intrigue with it for
perhaps a while it remained within some
kind of media bubble but it's very much
broken out of that
um a lot of people are laying claim to
knowing who the individual in question
is
um I suspect these are these wholly
unverified
um and I think that this is just going
to continue I think the pressure and
intensity of that pressure is going to
mount and mount and you know who knows
where it's going to end
and if we take a look at the Daily Mail
Pippa
um they suggest in a male snap poll that
one in six people know who the Scandal
hit BBC star is millions they say can
name the BB star embroiled in this
teenage sex photo claims and the
difficulty of course is all of those um
innocent BBC presenters who've been
swept up in this I suppose
yeah so we've had a variety of big names
from the BBC coming out on social media
in the last few days making it clear
that that it's not them
um which has just led to more
speculation as to who the individual
might be and it's interesting to think
about why
um the media hasn't hasn't uh named the
individual because there's not a an
injunction in place or anything like
that but there's obviously concerns
about both deformation and breaching
privacy
um and if you're if you think back to
2018 Cliff Richards obviously won a case
um over the BBC's coverage of his home
being raided after before sleeping
accused of historic sex offenses and
then the Supreme Court last year
um ruled that a person investigated for
a crime has a reasonable expectation and
privacy so these are all the
calculations that media lawyers are
weighing up
um and of course that applies to social
media as well people treating
speculation open themselves up to risk
of defamation and libel um so
understandably uh media organizations
are being being very cautious and
actually noted there was a second story
um in the sun tonight which was
speculating that some MPS were
considering naming the individual in the
House of Commons obviously MPS of
privilege which um effectively protects
them from
um from Liberal laws
um and if if they if they make an
announcement in the chamber of the House
of Commons and it's not this this
wouldn't be a first I don't know whether
that's going to happen or not but if
your customer went back to 2011 when
John Heming the lib demp
um acted Ryan Giggs during a debate on
privacy orders uh after he took out an
injunction
um over an affair with the TV reality
star so there is there's some precedent
there although I suspect given to these
events and giving the sort of
conflicting uh accounts that we're
hearing from The Young Person's lawyer
on their behalf and the one hand and The
Young Person's parents through the sun
on the other you'd think that any MP
considering doing this would be would be
weighing weighing it up very very
carefully before they before they get
involved in in the whole debate yes and
the The Daily Mail says the BBC Chiefs
are facing a near Revolt from mutinous
fellow stars who are said to have put
massive pressure on their colleague to
identify himself after internet trolls
falsely accused others of being the man
that's picked up by the eye as well
um suggesting that the BBC unnamed star
came under pressure from within the
corporation to allow himself to be named
but there's pressure to Annabelle on the
effectively judge shaped privacy laws we
have in this country after that so Cliff
Richard case that Pippa mentioned
um that in the early stages of an
investigation someone has the right to
to privacy to anonymity
um which is where we're at now
I think it's right that uh we've been
treading immensely careful with this as
you say prominent presenters Gary
lineker Jeremy Vine Nikki Campbell among
them uh have issued statements
distancing themselves from this Nikki
Campbell actually potentially taking it
a step further very affected by what he
has seen on social media on Twitter uh
in particular
um and it's of course it's it's
extremely sensitive it's extremely
problematic for our public service
broadcaster it's not just uh the
internal com so that has clearly been uh
immensely uh challenging and problematic
not least Stars perhaps feeling as
though they weren't duly protected by
the corporation but externally as well
it seems as though the reporting has
been at the BBC reporting on itself
fully aware that it is finding itself at
the center of the story it is becoming
the story not knowing necessarily what
it is reporting on and really just
adding to this complete fog around this
story complete confusion over you know
what we know and what we don't know and
it's increasingly looking like we don't
know a lot more than we do yes and
that's picked up actually by this is the
Scottish edition of the Metro
um Nikki Campbell um the radio 5 live
presenter who talked today about what a
difficult weekend it had been my pain at
Phil's BBC web claims
um presumably quoting from his radio
show earlier today
um there's confusion too about the
legality of this now we you know we
don't know
um how substantiated any of the
allegations are we've heard from the
young person at the center of the BBC
Scandal saying the caves of rubbish
which is what the Guardians picked up on
your paper
um by your media editor Jim Waterson
he's written Lots about this already
this weekend I know
um the young person at the center of a
scandal over a BBC presenter reportedly
paying for explicit pictures issued a
statement claiming the key allegations
were rubbish
um the point I was going to make though
is that the legally confusion about
whether any criminal activity has
happened here
um on the on the original
um claims the law on indecent images
treats all under 18s as children pepper
um unlike if you had met somebody in
person for example so there is confusion
on the law about this as well
yeah I think this is why the Met has has
not yet
um decided to launch a formal
investigation
um because they don't they don't believe
that the threshold for a criminal
investigation
um has been reached but they issued the
statement earlier today in which in
which they said that uh they would have
a carry out further work but it would
fall short of the formal status of
criminal investigation which would give
them uh officers the powers of arrest
and search for example but detectives
are apparently trying to work out what
if any criminal offense may have been
committed by the suspended presenter as
you rightly say Anna there is a
suggestion that
um uh any any young person
um the young person sent any explicit
pictures when they were 17 that that
would count
um as images of child sexual abuse which
is obviously a very serious criminal
offense but if the explicit photos
weren't exchanged after the young person
turned 18 then it's possible and bear in
mind that I20 that's possible that no
law was broken
um and obviously the age which
individuals can share explicit photos is
higher at the age in which they can
illegally have sex so the legalities of
this are quite complicated and the
police are obviously treading very
carefully
um while they assess uh the information
that they've already got and the son has
said that they've seen evidence that
supports their parents concerns
um but we don't I think know really what
that is beyond a suggestion that they
may have seen
um bank statements uh with transfers of
money and possibly screenshots
um or exchange messages between the pair
um and I think there was one one
reference to the mother
um seeing the presenter on a video call
but beyond that it's very difficult to
know how much how much evidence son has
one imagined that the official for
publication legally would be pretty high
but we've not seen that ourselves of
course so it's difficult difficult to
say and as we say the police haven't
launched an investigation yet so um they
they are still looking at it but
obviously haven't made their minds up so
um I think for the BBC perspective
though the one thing just to add is that
Tim Davey is going to be addressing
staff tomorrow
um I think that not not about this but
he is due to answer questions as he
meets journalists to launch the
corporation's annual reports and he'll
have um the corporations interim chair
with him there as well Dean Ellen close
Stevens so first public appearance in
the role since she took over after the
Richard Sharp Scandal he obviously had
to stand down
um over perceived conflicts of interest
rise so you know the BBC has had a
pretty turbulent few months itself
particularly about senior leadership and
while the Prime Minister and the culture
secretary say that they have faith in
Tim David that the um director General
uh at the moment uh is going to be
interesting to see whether that stands
firm in the coming days